breaking off with a girlfriend what's
happening man
um so I'm trying to unplug myself
uh basically like made some good
progress this first year I guess like
started around the first of the year set
a goal to ask a new chick on a date
every week
um had horrible success like the first
three months and then um went on a date
with this chick
and we uh I actually didn't like her
that much at first but she kept bugging
me she wanted to hang out
um and so I kept hanging out with her
I've I've dated a couple chicks like
went on a couple dates with uh a couple
other chicks since being with this one
but mostly consistently with this one
I guess like when do you know because I
don't have a lot of options outside of
this and I think I'm I think I need to
break things off with this girl because
she's not really adding or complimenting
my life
um but I don't know why is she a drain
what is she doing that's making her
drain on your legs
very like fit active
kind of lethargic
like when we first started hanging out
she said she was really active and loved
to do things
um but like we went up for a little
mountain getaway like a couple weeks ago
we went on a hike and she rolled her
ankle and I know everybody says that's
[__] up
she rolled her ankle walking
yeah I know well she did and uh so she's
not out of his shape she doesn't walk
that off though no and she like started
crying and it was uh like I didn't
really know what to say and then I kind
of like brushed it off because I got
whatever like you know maybe she'd trip
it's people make mistakes but um I went
on a bike ride with her like a couple
weeks ago rode with her like the whole
time it was like an out and back
route and then at the turnaround point I
kind of just like
I kind of like left her in the dust just
like kicked up my Cadence started to
Pedal have fun but I like every so often
look back and
um
I've stopped at a checkpoint and like
waited for her to catch up and um she
says to me she said the first thing she
says like you don't have to make this a
race and uh
uh I was just like well like I'm not
really trying to race I'm just trying to
have fun
um and I kind of brushed it off and then
like 30 minutes later I was like hey you
know I think that was really frustrating
me how you said that I feel like you're
nagging me
um and then uh
we had loose plans to go to dinner last
week and then she she uh I forget what
happened she did something that pissed
me off and I just kind of like ignored
her for a couple hours she liked on you
did she flake on me yeah no I I actually
flaked on her
um I went and dropped off some paperwork
to one of my employees and said like oh
so you're running your own business yeah
yeah I've called in before I have my own
HVAC business cool
um so basically send me a question for
you so if she's out of shape why did you
go out with her
uh not a lot of options to begin with
and it was like
uh we met online so uh you tell me which
I you're gonna roast me dude um okay
cool blind so like blind date we matched
on dating app
and uh I saw like you didn't have a
photograph of everybody oh she actually
looked good and good in this I'll say
that uh well they always look good in
the photos exactly they do um was there
like older photo like five years older
30 pounds later like what are we dealing
with here yeah there was
okay so she catfished you
yeah it's not the worst one I've ever
had for sure I mean yeah but you got fat
fish though right I mean she lied about
what she looked like
yeah and she actually looked pretty good
when when we met up but like it's been
about four months now and she's
definitely like dropped off and um I
I've confronted her about it and told
her and that's why she started riding a
bike she went and got a bike so she is
like trying to work on these things
because let's get some frame around what
we're dealing with here like what's her
height and weight roughly
uh she's probably like five eight one
forty one fifth no she's not five eight
she's probably like five six one forty
one fifty
um but not fit you're saying like she's
more flabby yeah and when like when we
first met she was like just a little bit
flabby and now it's just like gotten
worse and um yeah these are like things
that you can't fix like how old is she
25 yeah I don't I don't recommend guys
try to fix any of this stuff like
especially in our 20s it's like look man
like women are usually their most
beautiful that you know their most like
the hottest the chick is ever going to
be 22 23 years old right I can go back
in my yearbook and I can look at any gal
that might show up on on Facebook that I
went to high school with and she looks
way better in her high school graduation
photograph than she does today right
like this is as good as it gets yeah so
if you're dealing with a chick in her
early 20s and she's like eh or she
doesn't really like blow your hair back
she's kind of like average or
average-ish or whatever she's you know
not really looking like what you like
don't even bother dude like save your
save your time for your hobbies for
interest for you know Building A
brotherhood friendships and date you
know whenever you can but don't waste
your time on yeah because like yeah like
and just gets worse
dude it just gets so much worse you're
telling me exactly what I was hoping to
hear thank you I appreciate it so so I
mean the question I have is if you
already knew the answer to this then why
did you do it uh I think that's like
something I need to work on I think I'm
afraid of being alone I've I've been
alone for a very long time and it is
like convenient to have somebody around
who's available
but it's getting to a point where it's
like it's not the juice isn't worth the
squeeze anymore yeah I mean it was nice
because like it was a I was on such a
dry streak for like
I think I didn't have sex for like a
year prior to that what do you live like
in what part of the states uh I live
nearby Boulder Colorado okay like like
north of Denver North of Denver like
what's the population like uh a hundred
thousand okay so it's a it's not a large
town then for sure so I mean your
options are going to be smaller how old
are you 27. are there any colleges or
universities close by yeah University of
Boulder is uh or CU Boulder is like 20
minutes I work up there pretty often
yeah
yeah why don't you date those girls
they're a little bit younger they're
probably a little fitter
um we got something going on
mature girls like that um I'm not like
higher educated I am like I'm
self-employed I have my own business but
um it seemed like uh my whole life like
I just never got a lot of attention from
those girls uh when I was younger I was
a like I was super skinny kind of a nerd
I played soccer like here in America I
mean what do you do for living again you
said you're an HVAC yeah I started my
own business like three years ago
and what do you do you like install
these units you sell them service
install repair maintenance yeah mostly
residential but I'm trying to transition
to commercial uh my dad owns a
commercial company here and he wants me
to take it over what do you pay yourself
annually
last year I I'm 55 is what I made last
year oh you should be paying yourself a
lot more after three years if you're
running the thing and you got employees
oh set my taxes up I don't claim a whole
lot um so you're running most of it
through the business yeah like actually
vehicle gas yeah client meals
entertainment probably more like 80 last
year if I had to guess and I'll probably
do 30 more than that this year yo look I
mean you're gonna like there's there's
people in the chat going on about your
mustache kill the mustache the mustache
we'll deal with the look in a second the
the like the like the school chicks that
think that they're better than you
because you're blue collared and you do
HVAC sort of work
um I always find that funny because
I had this conversation with a buddy of
mine years ago and it's like you know
um you could be a junior lawyer uh here
in Toronto making 75 000 a year and a
chick would probably pick him over a guy
that's been running his own I don't know
a plumbing company for 10 years make
paying himself two hundred thousand
dollars a year right speaking to The
Prestige of like the lawyer name it's
like you know you could be potential
husband material father material you
know stuff like that
um there's some women that put a lot of
weight in education and degrees and you
know stuff like that
um that loses uh relevance over time you
know if I'm being honest with you like I
don't even have a University degree and
I make more money than anybody they ever
went to school with that has University
degrees most of them are [__] that
did nothing with their lives right so it
doesn't have a lot of relevance as time
goes on
um when you're in your 20s you might get
some pushback just ignore those checks
oh okay you think you're special fine
you know go [__] yourself with your you
know liberal arts degree painting basket
weaving underwater whatever it happens
to be it doesn't matter it's not
relevant you want to choose women that
that that that are choosing you
um the relevance to the people talking
about a look in the comments section
right now about killing the mustache and
you know getting a look sort of thing I
don't know that like I don't know what's
up with the mustache like is that the
best that you can grow oh yeah man I
can't grow facial hair shave it then
yeah like it's yeah if it's not filling
in then it then it looks like weak game
right I mean if you're gonna grow a
mustache and you need something solid I
just tried something new yeah fine like
I get it but I mean if you want your
options to expand and you want to get
more women choosing you then you want to
kind of like lean into confidence in a
look that's really going to sell for you
and I think that the mustache does you
at this service it kind of makes you
probably look younger than what you are
which is fine if you want to date you
know super young chicks but I don't
think it's a look that suits you right
you ever get like you know women or
friends that say hey George you kind of
look like so and so from Hollywood or
musician artists like you ever get that
uh in no not really I don't think so you
never get a look like somebody says you
know you look like so and so no a lot of
people tell me that like my voice sounds
like either
um Better Call Saul
um but I've never got like a look before
no okay I got these big ears dude they
like that's the only thing that we're
getting big ears from man your ears are
totally in proportion in your head
um I think they are now I think when I
was a kid I got bullied a lot for it
because I was like very skinny had this
like skinny neck I'm very athletic now
that's your height and weight
11 190. okay so you're in pretty good
shape yeah yeah I'm in really
really good good well I mean like as far
as the look goes like you know clean
yourself up so you look a little bit
tighter you know what I mean like kill
the mustache you know your hair looks
tight you know so just make sure you
don't let it get all messy or sloppy or
the fade sucks you know Fades look
really good I know guys that go on
weekly you know for a fresh fade I get
my beard done on a weekly basis but I'm
also broadcasting weekly too so it's
it's got to look clean but if you live
your life in that way and you have a
high opinion of yourself a strong
opinion of yourself and you're not
bothered or like pushed aside by women
that aren't choosing who cares dude
there's eight billion people on the
planet half them are are women and you
know what some of them live in your
vicinity and put yourself out there uh
don't waste your time with women that
catfish you fat fishy you know whatever
it happens to be like if you meet her
and she looks nothing like her
photograph or she's not attractive
enough for you then just politely say
hey you know what this isn't what I
signed up for I got other things to do
but you know have yourself a good day
and just let her know you know you
misled me with your photography women do
that like like women tend to lie about
what they look like men on dating apps
tend to lie about more more so things
like height and success
um like they'll stand beside a Lambo in
their photographs even though they don't
own a Lambo they might stand beside
shorter people that look taller sort of
thing or they might cut out cut out
taller people in photography like those
are the things that women typically feel
misled about on online dating so as long
as you show up being as tall as you they
think you are right and that's really
all that matters right uh just don't lie
about your you know your success in life
and just filter through it man you got
to dig through a lot of dirt to find
gold right and um you know you'll get
there
I appreciate the feedback and uh the
Candor too yeah I'm gonna go shave this
mustache right now yeah kill it man kill
it just you know use that time on the
haircut because you got a good you know
like a solid good hair uh head of hair
sorry I should say
um what color are your eyes
it's all green Hazel hazel green eyes
and blonde hair super rare chicks dig
that dude they do you are correct right
so capitalize on it I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out